all right so I know nobody's really
anticipating this movie but if you are
peace of mind this will be a spoiler
free review no spoilers in this review
and when in doubt I will be Vegas
which would probably work against us
since the if there are things I didn't
like in the movie I probably have to be
vague about it here or speaks to the
fact that I should probably do a spoiler
review but I wouldn't do that until like
a Sunday at the earliest of whatever
here we go spoiler free review
[Music]
glass so glass is the long-awaited
sequel to unbreakable also part three of
the Shyamalan superhero trilogy are we
calling it that now point is it's
unbreakable split and glass and
essentially now there's mr. glass played
by samuel l.jackson Kevin or the Horde
played by James McAvoy and they're in
this facility where Bruce Willis's
character David Dennis and his soldier
villain and the arch enemy might just
team up to test the hero it's one
element in this movie anyway there's a
lot of stuff in here and quite frankly I
just can't deny it I loved seeing David
Dunn and mr. glass on screen spent 19
years man I've been waiting for this
sequel forever some people will probably
complain act 2 in this movie is slow and
it is slow but really captures the
spirit of unbreakable unbreakable is a
slow movie its strength is the fact that
it's a character piece no one's ever
liked Oh infinity war let me get you one
that'll really blow your hair back
unbreakable try that oh it's not
like that it's different kind of movie
really this movie grabbed me from the
beginning you have to reintroduce some
characters need to see where David Dunn
is after 19 years and we get that I just
found David Dunn's life Bruce Willis's
character in this movie very organic to
where he would be after all this time
and quite frankly mr. glass Elijah price
is one of the best villains ever Bruce
Willis actually commits in this movie
lately he's been kind of phoning and in
like alright yeah do write the check
great thanks I'll do this one in my
sleep literally like in my sleep you
will film me while I'm sleepwalking but
you can tell him this movie there's an
air of respect for Bruce Willis and the
character he plays and McAvoy McAvoy
crushes it really McAvoy's front and
center in this movie if you thought he
was great and split you're gonna think
he's great in this movie he's so good
just snapping in between the
personalities from back to forth not
even back and forth back and forth
implies - I'm not saying back and forth
with - I'm saying it's a game of hacky
sack in the 90s I was there I saw it
their world circles of these pimp kick
in a bag around that's how McAvoy is
with his personalities just on the fly
it's like when Willem Dafoe was talking
to the mirror in the Sam Raimi
spider-man Times about a thousand or at
least 12 that's that's reasonable I will
McAvoy being front and center is
entertaining
now we're gonna slide into the negative
after the positives were Bruce Willis
good James McAvoy good McAvoy he's
front-and-center why is it called glass
why is it not called the hoard or
something this movie is an unbreakable
sequel but it really feels like a split
single granted the second act
absolutely pays tribute to the
tone of unbreakable it's that
slow-moving psychological thriller with
characters you're invested in characters
you're invested in yes because you saw
the previous movie but characters you're
invested in nonetheless that's where
this movie really shines is when it
remembers where it comes from but like I
said I feel like this is a split sequel
which is weird that Shyamalan made that
call because I feel like the
conversations been oh after 19 years
were finally getting glass the
conversation isn't after two years were
finally getting glass because it's a
split sequel I was there at a screening
for split I the rest of the audience
felt like we were all like this is a
good movie and then the thing came the
twist and everyone's like oh my god
standing ovations we were from yeah I'm
enjoying this - standing ovation because
of one thing the fact that it tied into
unbreakable given that I feel like the
unbreakable element should have been a
little more prominent
mr. glass is in it he's important but he
doesn't do the most it's kind of
like he's the king in chess you could
say he's the most important piece but
mainly the king in chess is kind of sits
there like all right yeah I'll get my
moment maybe I can I can castle with the
rook over there meantime I'll just chill
also I feel like there were a couple of
I don't want to say retcons interesting
choices given the previous movies
there's something in this movie tread
lightly oh well I will tread lightly
no spoilers promised again should
probably do a spoiler review for this
after those it's like with M night
Shyamalan treated this movie like a
character piece or a psychological
thriller it was really good really
enjoyable when he started getting grant
ideas when he started treating this like
a superhero movie at least in the third
act or some superhero elements in the
first act I thoroughly enjoyed by the
third act instantly not as enjoyable and
I know it's like unbreakable is a
superhero movie what's the problem but
I'm breakable wasn't treated like a
superhero movie sure you could say by
the end it's a superhero movie but
really it's a character movie same with
split splits an interesting
psychological movie at character movie I
keep thinking about the structure of
this movie as a whole and why it really
fell short for me by the end from what I
saw the three action this movie have
three different stars like Act one
that's David Dunn's movie act two is the
hoards movie and act three well that's
mr. glasses movie but the problem is
it's unevenly spaced the setups pretty
fast as setup is which means Kevin gets
all the shine than the last act of
segment in which the title character
gets to shine is the sloppiest part of
the movie by the end it feels like M
night Shyamalan had three different
visions three different ideas as to what
this movie would be what he wanted glass
to be he couldn't decide on one for the
movie so he made these three ideas the
acts of the movie Act one was one idea
he had for glass act two is another and
act three is the other and by the end of
this movie Shyamalan just flexes his
Shyamalan muscles and he takes this
movie that started out pretty strong and
kept me engaged through the second act
and he well for lack of better term he
Shyamalan said which is a bummer because
a third act that falls apart that's just
detrimental in my opinion is easier for
a movie to comeback from a first act
that might not land or a second act that
might not land as long as they stick the
landing to the third act because the
third act is what you're left with
you let your third act fall apart well
that's what people are more going to
remember and I feel like that's what
happened here I'll say it's as simple as
this for me in terms of glass being in
Chapter three of an M night Shyamalan
superhero trilogy glass is fine in terms
of a sequel to split glass is
interesting in terms of a sequel to
unbreakable that I feel should have paid
those characters better tribute not so
much so it all depends on what you're
going to this movie for I was going for
the unbreakable sake well I left
disappointed so I'm gonna say glass is a
better time if you're drunk ya know it's
a party I felt like the audience is
gonna be split like half we're gonna see
this movie is unbreakable the other half
we're gonna say it's as flimsy as glass
maybe M night Shyamalan is a super
villain like maybe that's his plans like
all we live in a world where people
screaming your face about comic book and
superhero perfect another file make
a movie that I don't think anybody's
going to be on the same page for good
job in that super villain I'm onto you
alright so glass have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see any more
[Music]
you